what do you think men want from women
from what I see men are craving really
craving a woman who is attentive to them
who listens to them when
I craving someone who gives um some
physical touch being in the 40s most of
the guys are divorced I I don't meet too
many men that have never been married
out of the 11 only one no two was never
married one was really young he was like
34 and
when I touch them it's it's like this
this complete melting of them they're
like oh my gosh thank you so much and
you talk to them and you find that their
Ex-Wives were just they withheld sex
they were just mean they were cruel I
mean we're talking just and of course I
don't know what the the wife's side is I
don't know what they did as well but uh
have them to listen to them compliment
them I like your watch oh I really like
your beard oh that's so soft oh you
smell really good then don't get that
anymore they get get ah you're terrible
and you and I don't ask about their of
course their job I don't ask about their
money um I let them lead I they pick the
place to go I said absolutely sounds
wonderful I'll meet you there not so
much on like the short-term basis where
you're dating but like when I ask you
what do you think that men are looking
for like more on a long-term basis that
would that would turn them into a
boyfriend committed sort of long-term
relationship what I what I thought that
they needed was an independent woman who
could come with their own money MH and
uh basically describing a dude at that
point yes exactly independent has your
own money has your own car has your own
house right that's what that's why I was
told that's what men wanted no that's
not um when I think about someone who
you you say this a lot complement their
life when a lot of men can't cook so
they want somebody that can cook a
home-cooked meal someone that is who is
dedicated to them they have confidence
they feel comfortable they don't feel
like they are competing with other dudes
that you're a committed woman that you
are um that you are there for them that
I I think that they want to feel like
you think they're a manly man no matter
what it is that they're doing um that
you find them physically attractive
whether that is you tell them that or
you demonstrate that through uh other
physical
actions um but I not someone who's going
to nag and all day long um the longest
relationship I had every time he came
home I was sitting at the door and
waiting for him and opening up the door
hey I'm so happy to see you thank
goodness you're here and you think about
what most people come home to and they
get home to hey what's up and go you
know something and that's what I think
men men want long term okay well I mean
you've got some idea I mean there's a
little bit of neediness though right I
mean like the way that you're describing
the um one of the relationships you had
in last year it had it had gone for a
couple of weeks and then you had to have
this sort of talk a few weeks in um I
think that you want to wait a little bit
before you're hey you know where do we
stand you know thing right like you want
to sort of get to a month or two of
dating I think is reasonable within a
few weeks a little bit of a push I think
most guys out there um you know they
were dating a g for a week or two and
she's like so where do we stand
they they'd probably be like uh you need
to chill the [__] out because I barely
know you it's interesting because um it
was actually it was he had went out on a
date um and it was after we were were
talking and I said well if you've
already made a date with somebody we're
just we just started talking I don't
expect you to cancel the date then
afterwards I said are you going to ask
her out again and he could have said I
don't
know that I you know I just want to take
a slow but he saidwell what do you want
I said well I guess if you really want
to know I'm like I I want to a committed
relationship that's what that's really
what I want and then he agreed to it so
my thought is always well if you if you
weren't willing to why'd you ask because
you know there's either two points I I
want something or I don't want something
so understand though a lot of guys are
very uncalibrated when it comes to
dealing with women in long-term
relationships they really suck at it
they're like we've we've spent years
trying to fix this now I've got 1500
videos out I've got 200 podcast episodes
out collectively I've got two versions
of a book out another one I'm working on
I've I've done as much as I possibly can
in the time that I've been around and
it's very very difficult to try to
calibrate guys to that so I could
understand you having a conversation
where you're like hey you know um so
you're seeing somebody else and it's
like where do you want to go he's like
oh yeah let's be a thing you know and he
sort of just jumps right down it I could
see that happening um so it's tough for
women too right because guys don't know
how to lead they don't know how to
calibrate themselves to
relationships it's not easy um MAF I'm
will be working towards fixing that with
a course this year that we'll walk guys
through it step by step um because it
gets pretty exhausting having to repeat
ourselves over and over again so but I
can understand what you're saying there
so to sort of clarify that because I
wanted to sort of see where you're at
there's really three things that guys
want okay they just want to know that
you're useful to their lives like some
of the things that you're saying like
they want to you know they want to know
that you're touching them and that you
like them that you're loyal to them
that's kind of a given you know what I
mean like if you're with a guy and
you've had a conversation about you know
where you guys stand sort of thing it's
kind of understood that if you've done
that that he's expecting you to only
deal with him right that you're not
seeing other people sometimes you have
to overly state it you know like some
guys will have to you know overtly say
to him and like okay you know you want
to claim me that's fine if if I see you
out with any other guys having lunch
with you know with ex-boyfriends like I
don't deal with women like that right
like some guys will have to spell it out
or they'll have to correct the behavior
if you know she hangs out with exes from
the past and has lunch and stuff like
that those sorts of things which which
could lead to deceit or her breaking the
um you know the the overt contract that
you've made um so they want gals to be
useful to their lives believe it or not
you know can you cook you know if I'm
busy and I'm working on something
projectwise and you have time and you
see a pile of laundry can you run it
through you know the machine for me
these are all things that piss off
feminists because they like oh how dare
you do something for the express
pleasure of a man sort of thing you know
the patriarch has been oppressing you
it's like no that's just being a nice
person like when I take you up for
dinner and show you a good night you
know what I'm saying right
so all of that narrative that gals have
heard about you know doing nice things
for men take it all beat it with a stick
take it behind the the house bury it 6
feet under and just be done with it
because the kinds of guys that are
really going to like blow your hair back
and really crank your wheels and you
know get you really attracted to them
are going to be thankful and are going
to want to see you more if you're useful
to their lives so being useful is
incredibly important um being respectful
is is so important to dudes women
totally underestimate this they'll
they'll taunt men they'll um
they'll flick boogers at them you know
they'll do things to irritate them
they'll um you know they'll they'll
banter with them to the point where it's
not even witty banter or even fun it's
like you know you're trying to compete
or you're trying to be like a dude right
it's like I will like me and moof when
we're together doing [__] you know with
the the boys it's like there's there's
witty banter and that's how men sort of
like Bond and do things but I know that
women have been been raised now and
through culture and Hollywood and
society and music and all the sort of
stuff you know they've been convinced oh
well you should be like witty bantering
men the way that men do men sort of
thing and it's like no we don't want
that we want respect you know we be
women don't banter with each other
normally like I I've seen that this very
rarely like women don't do this whole
back and forth kind of [__] talking to
one another because they take that stuff
really seriously so it's always women
that talk about oh I want witty banter
this and that but you know it's it's
interesting because we do that in our
own circles because and there's a reason
behind it it's about I want to see what
this dude's made of I want to see if he
can take it I want to see if he can give
it back I want to test him and see if
he's a competent dude that can handle
himself and you know women are hardwired
to do that too [__] testing or
competency testing
but the the little Jabs in the paper
cuts like they add up and to them they
want a guy because women love a guy that
can has The Gift of Gab and is witty and
that can flip them on their head and you
know joke circles around them and stuff
like that because wit and humor is an
indicator of intelligence and those are
positive signals but it's it's one of
the worst thing like just such a huge
turn off when from a guy to hear like
just yeah chirps and this and that and
it's like look I got to hear this all
day from my buddies that are running
their mouths or I got to listen to
clients that are unhappy about this and
that that are like the last thing I need
is that from from you when I come home
or we're going to go out on a date like
it's just I get enough of this during
the day you know figure out a way to
turn that off and men want
peace and I think that women have been
you know misled and you know been told
that men want to be challenged I I was
um I don't know if you know who Dana
katrick is but you know I saw that one
yeah like one of the points of
contention that she had is well well
don't men want to be challenged like you
know don't they want like somebody
that's you know got a backbone to them
sort of thing and it's like no we don't
we want peace in our life you know we
don't need you to run us at the flag
pole when we come home or you know be
challenged over something like that so I
think women vastly underestimate
the respect component of long-term
relationships and how that is sticky to
a guy guys will keep gals around that
show respect for them not it's forced or
they're acting it it's natural right
like they naturally you know show
respect for this guy you know they'll
introduce them
um to friends and family circles and
there's and there's a clear you know
level of respect like you know if you
sit down at a table at one of their
family events you go and make him a
plate and bring it to him at the table
sort of thing right um so small small
gestures you know as far as use and
respect are super important but the
other thing too is and this is something
that um Dr Orion taban highlighted in
one of his videos and he said something
you know you along the lines of you have
to you have to be willing to do the
filthiest most disgusting and sexiest
things in the bedroom that you've never
done with any other guy that you'll only
ever do with
him right because we live in an era
today I think where women have been with
multiple guys I think it's kind of
accepted or it's or it's men that are
forced to accept that you know women
have shared their bodies you know with
multiple men okay
fine we don't generally like the idea of
running the numbers through our head and
going well was it 20 was it 30 was it 60
was it 100 what is but it's now okay
well what did she do with all those guys
that she's not doing with me so you have
to be willing to give him what he wants
in the B as long as you're not hurting
yourself or hurting him or others and
it's and it's something that he likes
that gets him like revved up be willing
to do it but be willing to do it
enthusiastically so you know to the
point of your mom's story that you know
she told you when you know she was
younger where there was a lawyer guy and
then there was your father you know sort
of thing and you know the first thing
that came to mind when when you started
to describe that story moth what was
it you're muted
sorry the story was one with the uh
lawyer what was the first thing that
came to your mind first thing for me was
Alpha
Widow finding for the guy from her past
that she couldn't lo oh I I know what
you're talking about so he was the guy
that she wanted that she couldn't lock
down that she always thought about that
she had hoped you know would take care
of her and let her stay home and be a
mom and she didn't get that so there was
a there was a degree of uh contempt
right and you know they say that
contempt is the is like the clock that
clicks down to the end of the
relationship when you see a woman have
contempt for a man or even the other way
around but is us you a woman that has
you know contempt for a man in public
it's very obvious it's it's like you
know she's literally disgusted by him
and annoyed and turned off and
frustrated with him not being able to
follow um you know these things so again
you know so being so being useful to his
life doing everything nasty in the
bedroom and being respectful so I mean
you know you talked about a few of these
things like not nagging him sort of
thing I'll tell you a story that well
after I did it I realized oh Justin why
did you say that I I was looking up one
of guys I was dating um his his his
address and the value of his house and I
was with him and I said you know what I
looked up the value of your house my
house is worth more than yours and I
afterwards I said why in the world did
you do that that was y'all I know I'm
learning I'm learning I'm getting there
I'm getting there that was just so
stupid I mean
it's that's look at look at mof's you
know reaction to that God you know
that's like saying you know my car is
better than your car you know I make
more money than you you know my house is
bigger than your house my house has 10
foot ceilings your house only has 8 foot
ceiling sort of thing you still got
popcorn on your ceilings you know come
on but then I and then I tried to after
I realized I was like oh it's just
because of the location I'm closer to
Atlanta than you are that's just that's
why were you trying to be funny like I
don't like where did
that I I don't that's an element of
disrespect yes it really was it there
was no reason for me to say that I mean
I was nothing you aren't even in a
longterm relationship at that point so
how do you ever get to the long-term
relationship if you're in the dating
phase and you're like hey Bob you know
we're having a good time tonight but by
the way I looked up your place on Zillow
and my place is worth more self-
sabotage yes you're gonna be like yeah
okay maybe it's that it's that old
creeping up of of the whole girl boss
thing I'm I'm so good why you should
have a great house you know why would
you want to talk to anybody else I have
this great house you know I have I have
all these these check off list and why
would you not want this but I mean women
never really share their pot of gold
with a men you know they they'll do nice
things you know they'll pick you up a
coffee they'll you know they'll pick up
the drinks maybe if you're going out for
a date sort of thing and you grab the
dinner like there's stuff like that that
typically happens but women don't
generally say Hey you know move into my
house take your $440,000 a year job
don't worry about it you know move to my
$150,000 lifestyle don't sign a prenup
and let me share all of this [__] with
you take the Tesla you know whenever you
want sort of thing right like women
don't generally operate like that so
when when guys see a woman that has more
than they have they might Target you
like a sugar mama right like they might
want to use you or try to extract from
you there are guys that will do that but
I mean why would you go out with a bum
that's you know worth nothing I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the fulllength podcast you
can find that over here that clips from
if you're new to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out